[Music]
um
it still fits
oh my god
i never washed it once come and drink
back together again
seeing as our family construct was just
a calculated rules that only lasted
three years i don't think that we can
use this
this term anymore can we oh great
so here's what's gonna happen okay
reunion then huh
and uh i want to say something right off
the bat
you haven't aged a day huh you're just
as beautiful
and as supposed to they stitched our
marriage
you got fat but still good
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i made mistakes choosing
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world i'm sorry
we had our orders and we played our role
it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me you were everything
rainer oh
[Music]
[Music]
one thing's for sure
[Music]
i'm done running for my past
[Music]
you